Good morning, Sean. Good morning, Jason Beatman. Now, are you aware not only if we made a cast change here, we've gotten rid of the Will Arnett, it's just you and me and now, but we're also on a cooking show now. That is correct. Six-can chili.
Yep, that's what we're doing. What are we doing with the six cans of chili? Well, we're gonna do all the meat and all the veggies you can handle. Okay. We're gonna triple the tomato sauce and we're going to put in four kinds of garlic. Did you know there's four different kinds of garlic? No, what are they? Can you name them quickly?
Garlic, garlic or garlic ear and garlicness. It's gonna have a big fan of garlicness. Yeah, it's gonna have quite a kick to it. And you're gonna be, well, you're gonna be busy in the, in the restroom for a while with this, but boy, it's a great weight loss tool. And welcome to Six Can Chely with Sean and Jason. So Sean was just saying how he's he's a little groggy this morning because he's still wearing his Oscar hair from last night from his play
So he's he did not shower after a sweaty theater performance just Well because I'm so fucking tired and I'm so hungry because I don't eat before the show So I had a massive bowl of spaghetti and ice cream and I think that's why I didn't sleep and I'm exhausted today They did a Raiders of the Lost Dark marathon. Was it last night or the Sunday? Last night, and because they were the AV guy who was here all day too, and I was here early, and then I'd get up for that, and I had the show of who cares?
Anyway, who cares? Did you ask your AV guy to join you in Scotty for the marathon? Yeah. Yeah. Don't laugh like that's not something you would do. Now, now let me ask you about the Raider's marathon. And my first question is why? Because the new one's coming out.
Sure, you got to get ready, Will. Oh, so you got to get teed up. Yeah, yeah. I'm so excited. You got to have everything fresh so you can tap your neighbor in the theater next to you and go, do you remember in part three where they kind of laid some breadcrumbs for this moment?
Yeah, man. I'm such a grouch. I'm such a grouch about this shit. I just realized that I'm like, just don't say anything. Are you going to go see the new Indiana Jones, right, Willie? You have to. I mean, yeah, I mean, it's the little boy and you dead. Yeah.
When did you kill the little boy? Our guest is laughing. Listen, our guest is laughing. Here it is. So the guest is getting, the guest is getting fucking impatient. So here we're going to go, you don don't wanna piss this guy off, okay? Because today we have our first world famous DJ on the show. What?
Okay. This music master is at the top of his game. Spinning and scratching for the fabulous and the famous. He's gonna tell us about his passion for music. His land speed record of 180 miles per hour and eventually will. Are you serious? We're having a DJ? Yeah, that's great. Nice, Will. He is undefeated, he has an undefeated record
in kickboxing. And is recent moment. This is a big and special thing. Yeah, this is like he always twits his earned. Recent momentum has been found in a new passion for acting. And this momentum has come in the form of multiple nominations and wins for BAFTA's Emmy's Saga and Golden Globe Awards, as well as box office earnings for his films reaching well over $9 billion.
So he's got some nice speed going here with his new passion. He's got a lot of stuff. He's also one of Time Magazine's 100 Most Influential People in the World. And most importantly was recently named People's Sexiest Man Alive. All of this and one man and he's here to tell us how he does it. Please welcome DJ Big AJ Big Dress, AKA Idris Elba. No way. No way. Woo. Oh, see. I was like, wait, what? Another classic Bateman intro.
You guys have no guesses on that? Oh, that was so crazy. Yeah, that's crazy. That's crazy. That's crazy. That kind of being mean. How much of that was accurate, Idris? All of that, right?
Yeah, kind of. Well, which part? Well, you are undefeated All of it, right? Yeah, kind of. Well, which part? Well, you are undefeated in kickboxing, right? Yeah, I had one fight. Okay, well, you lose. I'm defeated. And you happen to be a pretty world famous DJ. I led with, you know, that sort of second.
That I knew. Yeah, but you know that. I did not know that. I did know that. That I knew. Yeah, but it's, but you know, I did know that. I did know that, right? Yeah. Yeah. The box office stuff is true and impressive. The awards, the nominations, the land speed records.
All true. It didn't believe it. The land speed. It's a little embarrassing though, and I said, when you put it in the box, it was so good at every idea. You were all in one packet. It's like, it was this guy.
It was, did you have a motor? I was like, am I? What? That's why guy. It was the guy that you ever loved. I was like, am I? What are you talking about? That's why I was using the sound effects to make flatulent sounds to make, break it up a bit. Wait, did you really race cars? Yeah, I did a documentary, which is about, you know, the need for speed and why human beings are into it.
And somehow it talks me into trying to break a speed record on a beach in Wales called Penn's End of the Beach. And some Malcolm Campbell did it last. And the idea is to drive the fastest in one mile. So you drive as fast as you can, you get to the beginning of the one mile and then you hit it for one mile and see how fast you get.
Like a flying lap. Yeah. It's the most stupid thing to do it. Yeah, why would you do it on an inconsistent surface, like a sandy beach? Yeah, I don't get it. I don't know why they go to the salt flats in Utah either. Like, how about a nice piece of asphalt?
Yeah, so what happens on a beach at 100 miles an hour, what happens is you start to hydroplane, you know, you literally start to float. Yeah, and then 180 miles. But you said, let's go ahead and go pass that and do 180. Is that right? Yeah. I've done 160, and it was really, really frightening.
Yeah. That's not fun. What were you on? I mean, in, sorry. That was me and our friend Ben Silverman on the Autobahn in Germany in a rented Porsche. The LeFrendt? Perfect guy to have you. Oh, no, wait, you know what, he was paying attention.
This was a different Autobahn trip. I think this might have been, was this Will Adams? It might have been Will Adams. Anyway, it's scary, but I highly recommend it. Let me just, let me just say right now for the listener who cares, are there Idris Alba right now, as a U87 microphone,
which is regarded as one of the, this is as a guy who does this for living, that is the Cadillac of microphones. I have one right above me here. Why aren't you using it? No, I don't have it. I've got it. Why don't we get the benefit of that?
I don't use it for this. I mean, he is because, I don't know about that. Yeah, because you know what, I did my own tech. Okay, so before you guys come in and grace us all, usually the tech is down for 20 minutes and it's usually someone that's in here helping that. But I chose to do it myself. I don't like that.
Showing off. Yeah, sure. And I used my SM, and then everyone's really impressed because we did the tech in five minutes. It was like, oh, what are we gonna do? And then suddenly, my interface for those who care started buzzing, so I had to change for the Cadillac of mics. Thank you for saying that.
Oh, boy. And listen to how much nicer he sounds than you will. I know he sounds amazing. He sounds amazing. Your voice, your voice will, is out there. Thank you. I mean, I'll take the, I'll take the compliment from you because I think you've got a tremendous voice.
And I'm going to start with you. Yes, he does. Idris, I came, the first time I saw, I became aware of you was in the wire. And I'm, forgive me because I'm sure that you're beyond exhausted talking about it, but it's one of the, if not the greatest television program ever made. And you in the wire were absolutely for me, just, it blew me away.
And then to have like two seasons in and someone go, hey, you know, that guy's English. And I'm like, wait, what the fuck? Right. Are you talking about, we're obsessed with with with with Brits who can do incredible American accents. Here's the best of all time. Is it is a difficult doing the American accent? That's our that's our question.
Well, I mean, it is, yeah, it is to come straight from England and just jump into an American accent and be specific is very difficult. And, you know, I had been living in New York and New Jersey for about four years and auditioning like crazy and never getting a job. And I wasn't getting a job because my accent wasn't authentic enough.
And it wasn't until I really understood and lived the culture that I could sort of pull off the accent. But here's the thing, and I'm going to say this is a bit controversial because, you know, it has been over the last two decades, this big wave of English actors come to the States and do pretty good sound in American accents, you know, and nail it. And usually, there's southern accents, because southern accents and English accents are closer. So I was sort of part of the first wave of English actors doing pretty convicts in American. But if you listen to it now, you're gonna go,
hmm, wait a second, because you're hearing things that only now, because Arias are a little more tuned to English actors doing American accents. You can hear it, I think, when I watch the Y-O-R, I watch an episode, I go, oh my God. that only now because there is a little more tune to English acts as doing American accents. You can hear it, I think, when I watch the Y-O-R, watch an episode, I go, oh my God. I don't know how I got away with that.
I'll tell you, no, I tell you what, I just watched recently the scene where you call, I forget what season is, maybe the third season, when you call all the families, all the guys together who are the dealers, who are running Baltimore, and you're running that meeting, and you're running it like a business, it's amazing. Jason, I don't think you've seen the families, all the guys together who are the dealers, who are running Baltimore, and you're running that meeting, and you're running it like a business that's amazing. For Jason, I don't think you've seen the wire.
It's incredible. I saw the first couple of, many years ago, I got to get back in it. And you do the scene where you're like, where you got the kid in the corner, and he's on a no pad, and you go, motherfucker, are you taking notes of a criminal enterprise? But I was aware of it.
I'm, this is just randomly, it's within the last week that I saw that scene again and watched it and was like, again, marveling at like, God damn that is yourself, it's gonna come. Do you have a hack for the accent? Is there a certain word that drops you into the great spot you wanna be in? It's actually counting to 10.
Oh really? And doing, you know, the vows, AEI, OU. And cause when you do them, you know, they just, if you can flatten that out, then you can pretty much flatten a lot of different. Bet you ate is a big one, right? I ate four and a half. I ate eight.
Well, the way we see it is to eat eight. Eight is a big. I ate. And my. I'm from Chicago when I go back. We know. Very. Bye. How did the wire come about? Now, that was Alexa, Alexa Fogel cast cast that, did you know? Yes. Yeah. Great Alexa Fogel. So she saw in you something that we all got to know. So thank you Alexa. Thank you Alexa You know when I was I got to New York New York probably in I might say 96 97 that's why I moved there And the why I wasn't until 2009 so I got cast actually in 2000 and I had been auditioning for years I did maybe lower in order. Yeah, I did one episode of
the Lord and I did a off-board way version of Trotters and Chrysler. I think you and I were in the same episode. Well, were we? No. No, really. And I didn't couldn't get that much work. And Alex Fogo was one of the casting directors that just kept bringing me back in and saying you got something, but I love what you do. And then when I got the wire, she told me, she said, listen, when you go for this, you know, the guys are not interested in anyone
that's not either from Baltimore or East Coast. They're not even checking for guys from Chicago. No, this was me. And they're like, you need to go in there and just pretend you're from the East Coast. Don't be specific, just do your thing. So, all right, great. And at that point, you know, I've been living now,
I was practically doing that every day. Yeah. So it was a breeze until the fourth audition. And there's a producer there, there's an Irish guy, late-grade, of course, nice thing, you know. He sniffed you out. 100% sniff, really? Out! And it really, it was like the fourth callback, I'm like, I know. He snifed you out. 100% sniff, really? Out. And really?
It was like the fourth call back. I'm like, I got this man. I've got this. Just a dirty breath. And he was like, Idris, where are you from? Uh-oh. And it was that kind of where you from, are you going to dare lie to us, motherfucker?
Are you going to say the truth? Yeah. I mean, I really pause and I was like, oh, man. And I'm thinking about what Alex has said. Please don't tell him, I'll get fired, blah, blah, blah. I said listen, I'm from England, I'm from East London. And the room exploded. They were like, I told you, I want my money.
I was sitting there like, what's going on? No way. And that is so excited. And what did David Simon, how did he take it? Yeah, he was flabbergasted. He was flabbergasted. And it was then they said to me, well, great, listen. We want you to play String About.
Because I was auditioning for Ava and Ava and Barclaysdale. Yeah. And I was like, String About? And he had like two lines in the pilot. I was like, string about. And he had like two lines. Oh no. In the pilot. I was like, string about, okay. Which character's that again?
And he's like, you know, the guy just next to Ava. I'm like, okay, yeah, now at this point, you know, you even do this HBO pilot where you go back to England. We've been told between the Alex and I was like, I'll take it, whatever. Very nice. And then, so the period right after the wire, were there, was it a waterfall of opportunities and offers, or was it kind of slow growing?
You know, it was a good time. The wire obviously, the first audience impact was African-Americans. Because the Y grew. It wasn't hit immediately for HBO. By the third season, it was fever pitch. I was like a ball player or a rapper. Wherever I went in African-American neighborhoods, I was huge. They loved me. You're like string of bell.
And so basically, the roles that got offered to me in waterfall were really sort of stringer bell type characters, you know, like gangsters, you know. I just, I got offered all of that. And I worked a lot with Will Packer. Sure. At the time, had a production company, he was making films for, you films for the African American market.
And he gave me my first big lead role in a film. And it was, I think, the gospel. And, you know, from there, I could, you know, I got the string of films that were in that market, a little bit here and there, some back home in England. But essentially, you know, it was very much sort of the same type of characters.
Like after the wire, after even a big TV show, it wasn't like, everyone wants to offer you jobs, it just wanted to see you play that character, especially a string of bell, no spoilers. You know, I have to stress. You know, but I get that, I relate to to that that people want you to do the thing. They're like, do the thing. And I get I used to get that a lot.
We're like, you know, act like an idiot. More. We want to see you act like an idiot all the time. And they'd never seen a rest of development. They were just like, they just see my face. He's pretty dumb. Yeah, they were just like, stupid face.
And they were like, be dumb dummy. Be even dumber than you are. Even dumber. even dumber. Even then I took that over from well. So now are you DJing the whole time? So you're your your into music. I love this. You're playing playing music as well as DJing before, during, and currently, right? Like you've never stopped. Tell us about that and where that music passion came from. And you know, I was 14 when I decided I really want to become an actor. But at that point, I had been DJ and you know, pretty much like 70. Like my uncle was a DJ and I used to DJ with him.
He's, you know, African man, African weddings, African Christians, Christian. And where is this? what part of England? So I'm from East London, but the community of West Africans in London was sort of spread out South London, East London. So I used to go with my uncle and DJ, and basically, whenever he got too drunk to finish, the DJ said, I wanted to be up there, just trying to finish up for him.
And how old are you finishing up? Dude, I started around, I was about 12, there just trying to finish up for you. And how old are you finishing up? Dude, I started around 12 and you know, way into my teens and then standing on a box. Standing on a box. Actually, it was tall. It was a big hit. So, you know, and I had a beard by the time I was 13. So people just thought I was a...
Wow. Sean Till. Sean, you took a beard to prom, right? Yep. Hey, did, did. So when, so you were 14, you took a beer to, to prom, right? Yep. Hey, um, did, did. So when, so you were 14, you just, you just, I was like two seconds behind you and that. You decided you, I caught it halfway through, too.
Yeah, I know. Yeah. So, so you're 14, you're DJing, and then you're like, what? You're like watching TV, or you're doing, you're taking drama at school, or what's going on that you go like, yeah, I want to do that I went to a boy school Trinity boys and You know this school was pretty rough and you know, it was really sort of sports and academia
But drama I was good at sports. It's okay with academia, but drama. I was awesome Yeah, and my drama teacher miss McFee. She just thought I was very talented sports. Okay, Vacademia, but drama, I was awesome at. And my drama teacher, Miss McFee, she just thought I was very talented, then she thought there's something there. And in a boy's school, everyone just uses drama, drama class to just piss about and have fun, right?
But I do that shit. Seriously, I was like, I really love doing this. And she, when I was time to do my finals exams and everything, she was like, Idris, are you serious about it? At that time, I was like, no, I'm going to be a radio DJ. I wanted to play music on the radio. That's what I wanted to do. She's like, okay, that's good, but you should not give up on acting. You're very good. And you know what I did? And then last year, I said, actually, miss, I'm going to, all right, tell me what to do. And I'll do it. So she enrolled me in
the next stage, which was a college course that was specific about performing arts. I did that for two years. And then at that point, you know, I literally was 18 years old and I got my first job at 19. Wow. Do you remember some of the stuff you were in high school? Like were you in like classic plays and musicals that all high schools do? No, no. The... I draw my classes was more improvisational, you know, and a lot of Neil Simon. Yeah, that's the thing I'll do. I did play Lenny in Of My Semendo. Do you know the plays, the Forner or the Nerd? Do you know those two plays?
I don't know. Thanks so much for 7. Why, Sean, what was your point? Hey, it was those were those are two very very very very huge popular plays for high school well and beyond and they they guy because Jason said Neil Simon he was supposed to be like the next Neil Simon Larry Schoo wrote those plays and there are massively huge Successes and his mom was my Spanish teacher in high school. Oh, so.
Oh, that's the best. Oh, yes. Oh, yes. Yes. Sorry, when you said, OK, yes, OK. But yeah, your Spanish teacher is mom, yeah, for sure. Thanks, Sean. All I want to talk about is Prometheus.
OK, go ahead. We're going to get to that. No, we're getting there. We're just, we're inching our ways through his life. Hey, listen, first job at 19, first like professional job, like getting paid. Yes, it was, first job was actually this little crazy commercial about getting your bike stolen and I played a guy to go, my bike stolen and run up a hill and did a bit of acting. And then I got a TV show, which was a kids TV show.
I was 19, but I was playing someone that was 16. Oh boy. I was part of the gag. I was just a bit big for school. But yeah, but you know, I wanted to go back, you know, I'm really the worst guy when it comes to like, who wrote what, what was in what like, you know, you'll get along with Jason really well. Yeah, no, he doesn't remember anything. Yeah, I'm Jason.
What did you do this one? What do you, what do you have for breakfast this morning Jason? Well, I'm still sort of picking it out of my teeth. So that's helpful. It's a whole get a oatmeal. He doesn't remember shit either. I appreciate that. But listen, the podcast is called Smartless.
I came for the less. Yeah, sure. That's why there for the less. Yeah, sure. That's why we're the way to. There's always less. Welcome to the party. And we will be right back. Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. Now, I have had ups, I've had downs, I've had clarity,
I've had confusion. Nothing has been more helpful than talking about it with somebody close in my life. And if that person's not around, sometimes a therapist has been and it's been great. Now, nothing could be more convenient than a therapist that's at the other end of a phone, right? Sometimes in life we're faced with tough choices and the path forward isn't always clear. You've got a bunch of different options. You're not sure which one to pick, you know? With your dealing with decisions around career, relationships or anything else,
therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life. So you can move forward with confidence and excitement. Trusting yourself to make decisions that align with your values is like anything, the more you practice it, the easier it gets. So trust me friends, talk to a professional really helps. If you're thinking of starting therapy,
give better help a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. So now I may have said, therapists is on the other end of the phone, but it can be at the other end of your computer too. So just feel out of brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. Let therapy be your
map with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help aglp.com slash smartless. help, at kelp.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from eight sleep. We sure do. That eight sleep, they're very supportive, right? I mean, look, did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality, Sean? I have an eight sleep.
And science has shown that your body temperature actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by 8-sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet. The pod cover will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partners individual needs. It can cool down and warm up and adjusts based on the bed based on you and your partners, individual needs. It can cool down and warm up, and adjust based on the phases of your sleep and the environment that you are in.
My wife and I like temperatures different when we're sleeping. And that changes from day to day, sometimes. I want to call it, sometimes she wants to go, so I want to, sometimes she wants to, with the aid sleep, with the pod cover, there's not a problem anymore. No, it's easy.
No, that's right. I sleep very, like, I like to sleep really cool. In life, I run cold, I like to be warm, but at night, for some reason, I get real, real hot. So this is the perfect thing. It figures it out for me, and it tracks like REM sleep, and when you get up, and when you go to bed, and blah, blah, blah, blah, all that kind of stuff.
Seriously, as we were saying, while temperature is the biggest game changer the pod cover has other amazing features. For example, thanks to the pod sleep and health tracking you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights on how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine impact your sleep and overall health. Eight sleep they love you every morning right? They do and not right now invest in the rest you deserve with the eight sleep pod. Go to eightsleep.com slash smart list and save $150 on the pod cover by eight sleep.
That's the best offer you're going to find folks, but you must visit eightsleep.com slash smart list for your $150 off. Eight sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK, select countries in the EU and Australia. SmartLess is sponsored by SmartWater. Now how about that? Yeah, it seems like this is very overdue. The natural tie-in, welcome smart water. It's nice to have you.
And it is nice to have you. And you know, it's nice to have you because whenever I'm doing Broadway, which is right now, I'm constantly dehydrated, constantly, and I do what I do is I actually do keep smart water backstage, and I drink it any time I walk off stage, I pound it, I pound it, because I'm sweating so much. And I need to, you know.
You know, in the summer, it's hot, right? And how do you cool down on the summer? You jump in the pool, you shoot the hose on somebody, sometimes you throw water balloons at them, you know, you know, in the summer, it's hot, right? And how do you cool down on the summer? You jump in the pool, you shoot the hose on somebody, sometimes you throw water balloons at them, you know? Like maybe you maybe I should start filling a water balloon to smart water, but so much. That's a good idea. Then when they explode in your face, you just drink them.
Here on the podcast, we are smartless, but not smart water less. Oh, water is 100% vapor distilled with a pure crisp taste. It's pH balance and offers added electrolytes for taste. Could you say that maybe smart waters are partly responsible for your Tony win? I found so. As thousand, well, why don't you think them when you
accept your job? Did you not hear it in my sleep? I don't think you think them when you are in an ideal podium. Thanks smart water for my Tony. And it says here we're not allowed to say the smart water makes you smarter, but we can say it's for sip and while you're listening to your favorite podcast of course, keep it smart with smart water. And now back to the show.
Now what about tell us while we're still on the DJ thing. Didn't you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did
you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did you, did up and he was like, yeah, I was like, yeah. And then, you know, at one point, he was like, this man, I'm getting married. I was like, yo, that's amazing.
What is this? I went to the DJ. And this is, you know, we're just at this club about your card. No, you had my number. You made a request. I was like, I don't take, oh, hey, man, that's it. Now, you've got this thing on Apple TV plus called hijack. This is an intense, I'm
going to guess it takes place on a plane a little bit. Yes. What gave it away for you? I've just done a little bit of research. Now, Sean would like to know, do you have any crazy stories on an airplane? He's basically good for any of the junky questions that you're I love. Those are my favorite. Because I have a great, I have a great plane story.
Tell me. Yeah, let's do it. Sean, let's do it. I just can't hold on one second. I have a great plane star. Tell me. Yeah, my friend, please. Let's hear Sean. Let's hear Sean.
Yeah, Idris, can you hold on one second? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sean. Yeah. This is your time. Okay.
By the way, good to have you. It might be good. It might be my inspired. It might be good to have you. It might be my inspired. All of you to tell your airplane stories, me and my friend, Reina, you all know Reina. We were going to England for the first time. I was going to London for the first time in my life and we got on what's the brand, who
flies? British Airways. So we're in first class, we're like oh my god, it's like first class, like a hotel, right? So we're like let's get on the time difference right away. So we took two ambien and we're drinking wine, we just can't go to sleep because we're so excited that we're in first class on the way to England for the first time. And everybody in the cabin was completely flat bed sleeping, right? So I went around and came mere centimeters from everybody's mouth as they were sleeping
and I went and kissed every single passenger on air kissing. Air kissing. We were crying. Drunk, drunk, drunk, booze, and booze. And they're like, yeah. Was there, was there a soulful? If anybody would have woken up, cell phone footage of this event?
No, of course, cell phones. Yeah. Oh, man, boy. Yeah. Yeah, but, you know, honestly, if you're in first class or if there's anyone that's not been in first class, first class, you know, you're, if you have been and you happen to be up, you're just really curious to who else is in here. And I do walk around and just like, yeah, do do do do do do do do do.
Now, what do you guys have a fix for? I don't like to fall asleep on airplanes, although I do a lot, because you can't help but have your jaw fall open while you're sleeping because you're sitting up, right? Right. Right. So I see some people, I've seen some people, yeah, well, it's just not a great look. I've seen some people sleep with like a sweater over their fat over their head or something over their fat heads, over their fat heads. Or maybe is that what those little neck pillows are for so it can kind of keep your jaw shut?
A little bit? No. First of all, first of all, this is, this is, this is, sorry, it just can you hold on one more second. There's, there's no way. Who are you worried about seeing your jaw open? Distortus on your fucking private plane? Wait, I don't fly private.
Anybody with a cell phone, you know, it would be, it would be, it would be, it would be, it would be, the pilot on his way back to used the bathroom when it just, you're the only passenger. What are you talking about? Nice try celebrities, they're just like us. No, they're not. And what goes on up there in the front of the plane?
Oh, like it's like they're eating great. Anyway. Do you guys do you see well in the plane, Interest? Are you a good plane sleeper? Uh, yeah, pretty decent. And I usually try, I do fall asleep in that time period between, you know, sitting down and taking off. Oh, yeah.
So there's probably a bunch of pictures of me with my jaw open. Yeah. I one time I was flying over. It's flying from Newark to Europe. And they took an ambient years ago. Took an ambient. As soon as we start taxing, I'm like, here we go.
Put the ambient in because I don't want to, you know, we haven't moved from the gate yet. I don't want to get caught in that thing of like something's wrong. And then now you're on ambient. We take off, the seat won't go back. It's locked. It's broken. So I like, ding, ding, and I get the flat.
She comes to help me. And these two, it was a Scandinavian. These two Scandinavian flat intent. They came in, they just like took my seat apart and manually put it back. Meanwhile, I'm in the aisle. I'm safe. And the ambience kicking in and I feel fucking crazy.
Yeah. I'm like, have you ever been awake on ambient before? It's a nightmare. It's not fun. Well, listen, as I don't condone or take drugs, and I, when you say an ambient, I kept thinking you were saying, amblin' as in. Yeah. This is Spielberg. Yeah, just a little bit that you
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so I watch I watch all the amazes and those Ambien has produced incredible bad How old were you when you came from England to the States? I was How old were you when you came from England to the States? I was 27 probably. 27. And dumb dumb question. Yeah. Because I'm obsessed with people's first impressions
of the United States. What were the first things they were like, yeah, this is fucking a weird being. You go right into New York? I went straight into New York. When I moved to New York, I was 27. When the first time I got to New York was 20. I was 20 years old.
And I had just finished this two-year performing arts course doing everything. And in that time period, I learned about the Lee Strasbourg institution that lived in 14th Street from New York. And I decided to go to school. Yep. The abstracts at 10th York, and I decided to go there. And I sort of lived in New York for six weeks, practically in a YMCA around 14th Street.
In 1990? Yep, 91, roughly. How in the world? Idris, I was there at that same time. Serious? At the school, at least, at the Strasper? At the least, Strasper, yeah. No way.
Yeah. Are you serious? I swear to God. Wow. Did you guys see each other clearly? You know what? His thing, his thing. I didn't realize that you needed a visa to get in.
So I had gone over there. I was thinking I could just feel like, hey, I'm here, you might have just paying them. Like, nobody, you need a visa, student visa to be here. So I ended up staying in New York for six weeks. And the first thing that struck me, wasn't weird. It was just that it's food obsessed, like food everywhere. Like, you know, nice to go to a place called the coffee shop,
which is a little small. Oh yeah. It seems like it's great, right? You remember this one? Yeah. Right across the unit. It's great. Yeah.
And the food was amazing, you know, and for no money, too, it's just like, wow, I was just like, this is crazy. So when you go back to England now, do you notice a difference in the food? Like, are you like, are you miss American food? Or no?
No, I lived in America for 16 years and coming back to England. I guess the variety is just not as good. You know what I mean? The variety in America was just like, yeah, there's so much of it. There's so much, but there's almost, it's an interesting point.
It is, we are sort of food obsessed in that sort of, it's, but it's very, it's a very American idea, right? It's just like more, more, more, bigger, more come. And so they're constantly advertising, got it in your face and stuff, and it's not like that. Yeah. Yeah. It's very, if you like food, it's great, because the variety
is there. Yeah. There's like seven different sizes of cheese it. Ox, I always get the biggest one. Is there, Sean? Yeah.'s there. Yeah, there's like seven different sizes of cheeset boxes. I was getting the biggest one. Is there Sean? Yeah. Are there? Yeah.
What's it? What's it? Cheeset. There's some little colon cement. Hey, Idris, are you in England now? I am. I'm in London. All right.
Now, do you love going back there and working like Luther, you guys shot in English? Okay. Well, I want to get into Luther. When did you do the first series of Luther? Fuck, dude. Luther is so excellent. When was that first series, man? First series was in 2011, was 2011, roughly. And this was at the sort of end of my American journey. Like, you know, I'd been there for 16 years, roughly, about that point. And I was just seeing this glass ceiling hit me at the head, you know, I had worked, was, you know, a door respected.
I love America. I had a great time. I lived in LA. I lived in Miami. I lived in Miami, I lived in Atlanta, I lived everywhere, and I just could see that actually there was something missing in my career that I maybe if I went home I could, you know, sort of patch up and that was theatre. I wanted to go back to the theatre, I didn't want to do it in New York, I wanted to go back to the theatre.
And while that was happening, while I was making that decision, then the script came along and it was it was nootha. And I was like, you know, the BBC, first of all, you know, being in a lead on the BBC was like a big deal. And I hadn't ever done that in my career because I spent most of it in England. I mean, America. So it was a really big deal to be offered a lead role in a big six-part drama about detective. You know what I mean? It was literally that, oh, this is great. I'll take this. And that was the beginning of the second half of my career, I guess, you know, at that point.
That was, I mean, for me, that was one of those. And I was already a big fan of yours. So I was in when I saw you that you were doing this thing. I wanted to watch it. And then watching it, it was so kind of a so blown away but and also you're doing it with the great Paul McGann as well, who I adore from my favorite film of all time, of course, is With Nail.
And seeing Paul do that with you. Yeah. You know what was crazy about being working back in America in England was that I had to do an English accent. I had to just play an English character and, you know, Loose's London kind of like, you know, this kid that his dad was in the army so he traveled a bit, whatever.
But I couldn't really let go of my Americanisms. Wow. And everyone was like, and the people in the crew that thought that Stringer Bell was American was saying to me, your English accent is not bad. That's hysterical. That's funny. And I was home. I was like, yeah, it's not an accent, man. I'm English.
Like, your English took that way. Anyway. Now, how do you like the big, big difference between the grind, the workload of being a lead in a drama, a one-hour drama, where you're in every scene, working 12-hour days versus the big, huge budget films that you've done where there's tons and tons of action, where you might only shoot maybe like a half a page for like two days. Yeah. You know, where you're kind of sitting around a lot, waiting for effects to set up
or stunts to set up. What's your preference or do you like to just kind of do half and half? I mean, I'm going to film in the moment, which is very big. Huge setups, you know, we shoot. What is it? What is it? It's a film called The Heads of State. Yeah.
Heads of State. I play the British Prime minister and John Cena plays. Okay, guys, the, you are. The American president. President. Yeah. Okay.
Stay with me. And it's a big action comedy. And it's kind of like, you know, very big cumbersome setups. Slow, right? Yeah. And to your point, you know, very big cumbersome setups slow, right? And to your point, you know, Jay, I've come from, you know, TV backgrounds. We shoot very quickly. We move quickly. And we try to achieve the impossible very quickly.
And I love the pacing of that. I really do. I enjoy it. You got to be good fast. Right. You can't be good on take four. You have to take one. You have to take one. You got to be good fast. You can't be good on take four. You're going to take one. You're a good fuss. And I think there's a real sort of satisfaction to that pacing. But of course, you know, the big films allow you to really dig in and do some incredible,
you know, on budgets that are, you know. It's a weird, it is a weird thing. I remember that first time doing a big budget film and doing J.A. to your point, like coming in and doing like a, you know, maybe a eighth of a page or something on some big set up for the day. Right. And there's one line. You and me and the other person in the scene had one line each. We just had this.
I said something that she said something back to me. And they're like, yeah, this is really good. We feel really good. It's hard in the director and their producers are like, we got a great day and we're gonna get this thing. And we should just talk about this script, you know, talk about it. I go, the two lines, what are you talking about?
Like, okay, we don't need to have much of a conversation. You guys just want to run that a few times or workshop, like, are we talking about? And like, to your point, Idris, as you know, you're making HBO and both of you guys know as well. You're going like, you work on shows where sometimes you do nine, ten pages a day where you're running a day. Man, right, right. Right. Yeah. What about now, you're, you're, you're, uh, you're enjoying directing lately as well, too, right? And, and, and are you, are you, uh, are you enjoying, uh, bigger scale things, smaller scale things, what type of directing
are you excited about, right? I directed a bunch of small scale things, like music videos and short content, small type things, okay? Little bit of TV. And that was the beginning. And I just enjoyed the process of just being you know, being given a music video. I did a music video for the month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and a month and members. Isn't that why? And it was like a comedic sort of West China type of thing. Yeah, it was fun. Guys, you know, I, my wife and I have this big crush on Jason
Bateman, and you know, we've talked about this a lot. And you know, we even, we met him at a party, and we tried to do Jason Bateman, and then pressure was in front of Jason Bateman. It was embarrassing. But my wife was like, dude, you have a massive crush with her and I was like, ah, no, I just like the guy. And now, now, show up your back, Tat.
Show up the Tat to go on your back. Okay, so my bum actually. Now, and now we, we was in a month in a son's video. Oh, I know, this is just up to the ante. I know, it really has. Now, does your impression of Jason, does it sound a lot like a modem from the 90s? Yeah. Or just a dial tone.
Rail back. Jason, that's cute. Did you know that that, uh, Idris had a... It's not cute. We have, we have met a few times and he's a very, very nice man. This is a nice man. I love that. I didn't know that, you know.
Wow, incredible taste. What a credible taste. You're reaching. You're reaching. I know, I'm trying to, I love you too, by the way. I'm trying to get him to, I'm trying to get him to react. Robots don't react. Yeah.
You should have see his face. Two nerd questions. I'm a massive aliens fan, and I love you and for me this. And were you a fan of the alien franchise before? What was it like working with Ridley Scott and being on those sets, which were just so massive? And amazing. Yes, I was a massive fan of aliens.
I wouldn't say like, fanatic, I didn't know, you know, the whole, but I loved the massive fan of aliens. I wouldn't say like fanatic. I didn't know you know the whole but I loved the film I did just you really okay. I know everything about aliens. I'm gonna disappoint you then but I was a big fan of Ridley a have and and still am and I'm trying to remember but I'd worked with Ridley on American gangster and I'm He asked me to play a small party in American Gangsta, and then I got Prometheus, which is slightly bigger part. But so there's my second time working with him. Prometheus was, I mean, you know,
it's just like the scale of it was bonkers. And really is very much an actuality guy. This is just before the sort of like, you know, the sort of virtual production, you know, right, right, productions. Yeah. As I saw the shot, I saw a picture photo of the set. It's just unbelievable. Yeah.
Well, that stuff is amazing. But you mean like before the thing where they do the projection wall that we talked about with, yes, with Pharaoh. With Pharaoh. Yeah. That style of production is taken over and that's fair enough. But back, like, Prometheus and aliens, they built these sets, you know, and obviously and, and Prometheus was amazing.
And I remember the, the guy at the end, you know, the big white alien. Spoiler alert. Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, keep going. I love it. You know, I don't need to keep going because you know. So no wire, no Prometheus. Don't need to keep going because you know. So no wire, no permitheus, don't need to see those. Sean, tell us what happens in the scene. So the thing comes out and it's like, wow.
Yeah. And the guys like, yeah, by the way, do you know how that, the engineer tell them how they did it? They know by all means. By the way, you'd risked, did you know that, according to my calculations, I, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I show, and I, did you know that, according to my calculations, I... Yeah. Yeah, I sure...
I do know that that engineer, the actual man... That engineer in real life is about eight-foot tall. Wow. In real life. And you know what he's based on? They designed it based on... Partly designed based on staff, the staff, the liberty of the... Oh, yes.
The symmetry of the face. I know this. How did you ever land, Scotty? How did you ever get there? have partly designed based on staff, the staff, the liberty. Oh, yes. The symmetry of the face. I know this. How did you ever land, Scotty? How did you ever get that? Yeah, what are you? Now, you know, Idris and I have been in a film together. Did you guys know that?
No, what is it? What is it? It's called Zitopia, where he uses incredible golden pipes to voice the character of Idris. And he had Captain Bogo actually. Captain Bogo. Was he a panther or tiger? Neither.
Yeah. Oh, no, the water buffalo. Water buffalo. Yep, yep, yep, yep. Can you please tell me it's been rumored that you're gonna be in the new Star Wars movie? Can you please tell me if that's true? You can't speak about that.
No, I'm not in it, no, no, I'm really. There's a rumor. Because there's rumors that you're going to be in the new Star Wars movie. Can you please tell me if that's true? He can't speak about that. No, I'm not in it. No, no, I'm really. There's a rumor. Because there's rumors that you're going to be in the new Star Wars journalism, Sean. No, not so. Who started the rumor, Scotty? I just started it now.
Who started you one? According to the message boards that I started that. I read it. I did read that. I did read that a couple of places. But you may be coy about it, but who knows? I don't read that. I did read that a couple of places, but you may be coy about it, who knows, I don't know. Now what about, if you could have tickets to any concert tomorrow,
what would they be, who would they be for? Who's rocking your world right now? Any concert right now. Be science Taylor Swift. concert right now. Um, be science-tailor swift. Yeah, just have to be a swift. Okay, can it be anyone that I would like? Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay, so first of all, in England right now, there's this sort of production of Abba. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I've heard about this that it's great. Yeah, and I want to say it. Apparently it's incredible. Yeah.
And I haven't had a chance to do it, and I want to do it. Because it's a marvel. There's holograms and, you know, just incredible. And that would be a real, I love music, so that would be great. Are you an Abba fan? Are you an Abba fan? Yeah. Okay.
That's about the kind of yell. You can give us. That's what an endorsement. What an endorsement. No, hold on hold on listen, I am, but I mean, I don't know, I don't know, I just, you know, everyone loves it a little bit of a abba. Yeah, for sure. I did you know as you know, so, yeah, abba always works.
Well, isn't it, didn't they do that, the, the movie at Universal about abba? Mama Mia. Mama Mia, that's about abba right? Yeah based on the musical. Oh it's based on a song that Abba song and then they made them yeah and then yeah. The fans made two of those I think. What? Did they they did? I think they called it a second one I'm just curious. What do they call it? It was called Daddy Mia. Here we go again. Daddy Mia? Here we go again. Here we go again. Daddy. We are here. We go again. That's pretty good. But it was said, but it said more like there we go again. That's kind. That's kind. I actually like it. I like it. Pierce Brosnan sends his love. I love that, dude. Speaking of Pierce Brosnan, former double seven.
No, don't do it. Come on, please. What? Was that a noite? No, what I want to know is, I'm not, when, consider all those rumors that forever that Idris was going to play James Bond. What I want to ask, who is playing James Bond? There were lots of rumors that Idris was going to be James Bond.
Yes, I remember for years and years and years. Yeah, I heard that. Good choice. So amazing. And so my question is this, did you, was that process so fucking annoying dealing with everybody asking you every two seconds? No, annoying would be, you know, being asked about it over and over again on different podcasts while promoting
hijack that we've never spoken about. We're not speaking about it. No, I want to ask you about the process of being asked about it. Yeah, yeah. The truth is, man, I was super complimented for a long time about this. I was like, you know, well, this is crazy, You know, because James Bond, we're all actors and we understand that, that role is one of those sort of, you know, coveted type, you know, it's like being named sexist man. Oh, yeah, I can't really explain.
Oh, sorry. Oh, yeah, I can't explain that. He's so sick of that. Sorry about that. But, but being, you know, asked to be James Bond was like, okay, you know, you sort of reached a pinnacle, you know, that's kind of one of these things
that the whole world sort of has a vote in. And, you know, essentially, it was a huge sort of compliment that every corner of the world except for some corners, which we will not talk about, we're really happy about the idea that I could be considered.
The those that weren't happy about the idea that I could be considered. The those that weren't happy about the idea made the whole thing discussed in an off-point, you know, because it became about race and it became about nonsense, dude. And I got the brunt of it. Yeah, it's fucking bullshit. Who did get it? Who's playing James Bond right now? Who is it? Nobody now.
They haven't decided? Yeah, they haven't. I think they're all gotcha. All right. Who are you texting Jason? Are you texting your agent? Yeah, that's crazy. If you think for a fucking,
but you know, but interest is not available to play James Bond, because he's going to be busy doing hijack too. hijack, because hijack. No, but hijack is going to be so good. He is good. Recently out on Apple. The smoothest trend is I mean right.
He's also an executive producer on it now as an executive producer. Are you are you doing about hijack that's out right now? Yeah, yeah, an apple. Yeah, you're not seeing it. Yeah, come on. Yes, I'm going to see it. He plays a steward, right? A male flight attendant on it. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, screen, but actually it's reading. I need to get one of those. You can research and speak at the same time about people watching you. No, any of that stuff. This is incredible.
This is a real, this is a real, this is a smart list chat and giggle. So what do you play in hijack? Are you, are you, are you helping or you hurting on hijack? you hurting on hygiene? So I play. I play. I play a male prostitute who... Wow. So you're going to help me? Busy. There you go. No, I play... A guy called Sam Nelson who works in Dubai, or is working in Dubai, He's a business closer. He kind of, you know, does the last minute finalities
on to merge an merger. Yeah. He's married, but he and his wife are going for some crazy, and he decides to get on a plane to go home to sort it out. Okay. He abandoned his business. You don't see any of that, but you learn it later.
And on the plane, basically, there's a hijack. And he's so desperate to get home because he's a marriageist for him in the part of the day. He decides that it's a good idea to use his business negotiation, closing skills to basically figure out who this cell of hijackers are. And he decides to do it literally by brain power,
by trying to wear them down with personality and talking and asking questions and just getting under the skin And that's what happens nice. It happens in your fists. Well, that's what we do Yeah, well if you just talk to people in your nights, people instead of punching people you can get things And the show's great because it's it's like a real time so six episode seven episodes and it happens each hour Is in really oh that's cool. Oh, man. It's really cool. Yeah. So it's six episodes and it happens each hour. It's in real time. Oh, that's cool. Oh, man. It's really cool. Yeah.
Yeah. I love that. Wait, now, I also remember hearing something about you starting a marketing agency. Is that true? Yeah. I'm getting any of that, right? That's right. Why?
We just announced that, actually. Why? Oh, you did? I read it somewhere recently. Yeah. Why? And what's exciting about it. Okay, so Mark Boyen, who is a very successful, and owns this very successful marketing company called
Meroma. And Meroma and I have worked together to create a company called Sillyface. Sillyface is a market-set agency, which is, I guess designed to sort of find ways to inject, put, reignite, fun back into marketing. Look, you know, I'm a guy as you read my introduction. You know, I'm intersectional.
You can say that about me. And I think that in this day and day of a really smart consumers and brands wanting to be intersectional and trying to do different things, you know, there's a misconnect, you know. Consumers are like, really dark, your Mars chocolate, why are you trying to sell me music? Right. And you know, that whole intersectionality needs navigating, needs, you know, and I honestly, I find myself in a situation where I can actually speak on this quite intelligently
that I think it's okay for people to try different things. I think it's okay for, you know, I don't know, brands to want to reach out in different areas and try different ways to reach new audiences. But I think it needs to be done of integrity and smart. I think storytelling is at the heart of it. You know what I mean? I didn't come here with a marketing degree.
I'm a storyteller. And I tell many different stories. So as you read me, oh, so you kickboxed, okay, yeah, I can talk about it intelligently. It doesn't make it inauthentic that I did it, but you, you know, the story is that I did it. Here's my reasons why. So if a brand is at this junction where they're like,
I want to market into a new area, I'm not sure who to go to, you can go to many marketing companies, the world doesn't need a new one. However, Mark and I have this sort of philosophy around trying to do it in a way that makes sense for the consumer as well as it does for the brand. You know what I'm saying?
Cool. Were you always super motivated when you were a kid? Like, were your parents? Did they tell you early on, like, you got to go out there and get what you want? And because it seems like you just have no quit in you. I love that.
Great work ethic, yeah? I think the answer is yes, if I'm really honest, part of the overshare, but my mom, you know, she tried for children for a while, and it was hard, it was really hard. I came along and she was like, and I think she just, I guess she carried this little bit of sort of, you know, sense for the children that she didn't manage to bear and just wanted me to be the best I could be in wind. Go and go and go. And it wasn't like she was out there. She's not the cause. She's always telling me, you should have been like, why are you doing so much?
But she also just said, you know, my man, like, you know, we're here and then we're not here. So do what you want and go for it, you know what I'm saying? And absolutely. 100%. I don't know how that transferred into a work ethic. I haven't always, I'm an only child, so number one, I was always sort of like using my imagination way more than any of my friends I knew. I just had the imagination. I just kept going like, oh, what if we did this? And whenever I would play out as a kid,
go out to play with my friends wherever it's outside. I'd always be the one that's like, do we have to go home now? We have to go home, let's go, let's go, let's go. Because I didn't have siblings. And so I think that transferred to basically a place where as an artist, and here's a thing, guys, you know this, right?
We as actors so like, spoilt, we are privileged, we get offered so much that it takes many people years to get business opportunities, you know, Conversations and I look at I'm sitting down with the likes of you guys No, but I mean it's it's not a every day. You gotta tell you bottom before you can push up We promise this will be your bottom But trust me when I say from my perspective to come in here and speak to you guys who, you know, I respect so much, that's a privilege.
And to take advantage of that is something that I think is just kind of like why I find myself taking advantage of an opportunity all the time. So I DJ, I love DJ, I love DJ, so someone says to me, you want to do that role wedding? Yeah, of course. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Why not? I tell the story. Trust me, but I'm not one of these people that just needs to be famous, or wants to be famous, or just needs to do things just for like,
the most of the things that I really, really do, I don't really ever hit the news headlines and I prefer that. However, it is what it is. Yeah, I've noticed that about you. You're a massive star and you do not lean into it. You don't see a lot of pictures of you out, you know, movie premieres and cutting ribbons and, you know, lighten your hair on fire and say,
and look at me, I'm famous. You just, you just work constantly at the highest level with great people on great projects and you're just doing your work and the fame just comes with that, yeah? I take that observation and I appreciate that. I think I'd say that, you know, long-jevety, yeah, that's the goal. That's the goal, you know, and-jeivity, you know. That's the goal.
That's the goal, you know. And I think people can get exhausted, especially if someone like me, it's like, oh, you're in a rap video now, what the fuck, you know what I'm saying? Like, yeah, people can get exhausted. I think I've exhausted the three of you today, already.
Oh my God. Are you kidding me? No, I'm serious, I know I have, but the truth is, like, if you, truth is, I think people tend to find, especially now these days, we're all addicted to social media and wanting to feed the engine. We were talking about press junk, it's earlier.
I mean, those things are resentful these days. They want to know everything, everything about you. So I just prefer to say this, and then when I have to say, I speak, you know, how old are your kids? Are they looking to get into this business at all? Yeah, I have a nine year old, uh, uh, 21 year old and a 30 year old and my 30 year old, he's an actor and, uh, he wants, he wants to grow in that space. Um, my 21 year old is in, in my use, in my you study.
Nice. Yeah. Wow. This is great. And my nine year old wants in NYU studying. Nice. Yeah. Wow. She's great. And my 9 year old wants to be a gamer. That's great. Yeah. Okay.
Uh-huh. That was a profession not available to be a 30 year old and the 21 year old, right? Yeah. Laura. Yeah, although it's probably, don't they make more money on video games than they do in the in in movie in the movie industry? Yeah. Right? Doesn't like call it. It's been a while.
It's been a while now. Yeah, yeah, yeah. They've far subbed. All those big games, game titles, we'll, yeah, far outpace. One of those successful games, I think it was called a duty a few years ago, made more money than all the studios made. Combined.
Cool. Did you? Good Lord. It just, we're 11 minutes over. We have 10 minutes to go. We're very sorry. Oh, you 11 minutes in your life. I'm happy to serve it back to you if you come back out to LA anytime soon.
100% I'd love to. Do you guys do a live version of this on camera? That's all we have. We have done. We did that two years ago. And we may do it again. We're thinking about maybe doing it in Europe one of these days. But if we do, we're booking you in London. If that's not there, we filmed it. It's a doc that's out on Macs right now.
Sick. I'm going to watch it. And you know, if you want any merchandise, let's give them the merchandise address, Sean. Yeah, guys, let's send them some merch. No, no, no, no, you know what? Let's send them a hat. Let's send them one. Let's for sure send Idris hat. Idris, thank you for being with us, my friend. Can't wait to see you again. The great No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I appreciate you guys. It was very a lot of fun. Thank you, pal. Good to see you. Thanks, pal. Cheers, guys. All right.
See you later. Now, Andrew Selba. That's a man. That's a man. That's a man. That's a cool giant tall man. He's a very big man. I met him once, briefly, I didn't want to bring it up,
because there's a really good chance he didn't remember. So I just didn't want to embarrass myself. Yeah. Well, that was pretty cool though. You weren't the guy that he beat up in his kickboxing match, were you? Um, I'm not surprised that he's undefeated there. No, I mean, either. He's a big dude and I was saying like he was saying, he was in that video where he's
the guy who gets his bike still on the fuck with steel. He fuckwood steel interest hell but it's by a good like a dumb criminal I think it was called I think the song was called dumb criminal. Yeah, yeah, but he's he's a he's a he's a hero of mine that guy. Oh good. And Willie sounds like you've been following him for quite some time. Who me? Yeah. Oh, you're a big fan. Yeah. I'm a massive fan of his. I think he's got to jump back into the wire. Damn it. I know. He's been in like, you know, Thor and I feel like every girl I know has a crush on him. Yeah. Yeah. Well, suicide squad and fast and furious. And I mean, he wasn't I wouldn't talk about his part in the office. He did, he did some office work. It says Oh, yeah. He's also like the fact that he did a marketing company,
like he's all over, it's incredible. I know. It's very impressive. It is impressive. He's just like doing like a million things. That's what I say when I was like, we're not doing enough. No, you're not. You're really not.
My favorite line of this whole episode was Jason calling cheese its Colin Sament. No. No. In a fun color. In behind my back. They're not. I'm in some shit.
Cheezits are great. They are great to our friends at Cheezits. Yeah, you get a bowl of cheezits when you watch a movie like that. That's my popcorn. Is it really? Yeah, I love it. It's not popcorn. It's not. No, it's not a. That also will back you up quite a bit. Popcorn. Popcorn. Well, you know what? I just read popcorn's not great for you. Why? No, it'll go the plug. Just really?
I was just thinking about it. Yeah. Okay, Idris Elba is in a movie called hijack. I think he's trying to get to his buy. I am. Right, is hijack and his character he told us was working in. Do. Bye.
Actually wrote it down so I wouldn't forget. Oh, smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barberco. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.